good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday and today we're going to learn
how an anonymous French girl in the 17th
century helped create modern philosophy
with her cross ties Willy so excited he
got dressed up Hank first I'd like to
introduce you to Rene Descartes or as we
know him today
inigo montoya often called the father of
modern philosophy Descartes famously
wrote I think therefore I am
he was also a big believer in free will
and argued that the mind could control
the desires of the body a couple other
things about Descartes first off
slackers take note he believed in never
getting up before noon and he also had a
fetish for cross-eyed women which isn't
that much of a surprise really Hank you
know the famous axiom Gentlemen Prefer
Blondes philosophers prefer cross-eyed
women now Hank today Descartes would be
totally out of luck because 99% of the
cases of strabismus which is the
technical term for cross-eyed mists are
totally fixable but back in the 17th
century there were cross-eyed women
walking up and down the street
everywhere and Descartes could barely
contain himself
so eventually Rene Descartes realizes
that the reason he's hot for cross-eyed
girls is because when he was a kid there
was this super cute made of awesome
cross-eyed girl he used to play with
which strikes me as a little bit odd
Hank because when I was a little kid I
played with a lot of Star Wars figurines
and it's not like I grew up to be an
adult with a Star Wars figurine fetish
that would be crazy
you know like when Princess Leia and Han
Solo I mean I be that'd be nuts I'm not
no no way weird let's talk about
something else
so when Descartes remembered this girl
and he was able to connect the memory of
his childhood with his current adult
desires all of a sudden his current
adult desires went away showing that the
mind can control the body so this single
insight becomes one of the key Lynch
pins that Descartes uses in his defense
of free will in the principles of
philosophy how great is that Hank
I mean for philosophy obviously for the
cross-eyed women of the 17th century it
was a freaking disaster because here
you've got this smart and reasonably
successful albeit hideously unattractive
dude and he's totally into you when to
be frank a lot of other people aren't
because they think that you're marked by
the devil but then BAM he remembers this
girl from childhood and now you've got a
right Renee Descartes off your list of
potential suitors so Hank that's how a
fetish for cross-eyed women can change
the history of modern philosophy Oh
something important to tell you that I
forgot about you know Google the
Internet company the company that owns
the web site that hosts our videos
currently have more subscribers than
Google
I had to whisper it because if our
corporate overlords hear me say it they
might kill me hey I don't know how to
thank the nerdfighters for this amazing
and ridiculous turn of events but the
way that we generally thank them is by
letting them challenge us nerdfighters
this means that Hank and I will do
pretty much whatever you tell us to do
leave your challenge ideas in comments